All right, so I already mentioned at the top
of the show in the U s we had this long holiday
weekend for Labor Day.
Uh, the David Pakman show was off.
We debuted a, a, a long form episode that
we had previously produced on healthcare.
Uh, so many Americans because of the long
holiday weekend, didn't hear or see the ridiculous
and embarrassing Gong show if things that
Donald Trump said.
Now, unfortunately the rest of the world didn't
have a holiday weekend, or at least most countries
didn't.
Maybe somebody did.
And thus they did see and hear the absurdities
that came out of Donald Trump's mouth and
out of his Twitter account, uh, in the United
States, the weekend saw the approach of hurricane,
Hurricane Dorian, which is now a, a made landfall,
the most powerful hurricane on record.
At one point, heading to Florida, South Carolina,
Georgia, even parts of North Carolina, hurricane
Dorian as of last night, had already killed
at least five people by the time you hear
this, unfortunately, but realistically, that
number may be even higher.
And Donald Trump says, I've never even heard
of a category five storm before.
There have been four category five storms
during his presidency.
And of course, his reaction to the ones that
did damage and caused deaths in the past were
disastrous and atrocious reactions.
And responses.
Check this out.
What is he talking about?
Did Chairman and resilient and we will support
each other and we will work very hard to minimize
whatever the effect of what's coming at us.
We don't even know what's coming at us.
All we know is it's possibly the biggest,
I am not sure.
I'm not sure that I've ever even heard of
the category five.
I knew it existed and I've seen some categories,
floors, you don't even see them that much,
but the category five is something that I
don't know that I've ever even heard the term
other than I know
it's there when you've already been criticized
for your terrible responses to prior hurricanes
when Puerto Rico was hit or, well I don't
remember where it was that he showed up and
shot paper towel rolls like basketballs, like
some kind of game.
Maybe that was Florida, maybe.
Maybe it was Puerto Rico.
They're all kind of blending together at this
point because his reaction to all of them
was so horrible.
And then you say, who's even heard of category
five before?
You look at even more like you don't care
when you say you've never heard of an actual
category five storm coming and there were
four during your presidency.
You seem like you don't give.
You know, what about the people that are affected
by the hurricanes? Trump has said this before,
by the way.
He said in October of 2017 who's even heard
of a category five hurricane hitting land,
hurricanes, Irma, Maria and Michael were at
different points in that, in, in the evolution
of those storms.
Category five and then Donald Trump creating
even more chaos by saying Alabama's going
to get hit.
Alabama was not under threat.
Donald Trump tweeting quote, in addition to
Florida, South Carolina, North Carolina, Georgia
and Alabama will most likely be hit much harder
than anticipated, looking like one of the
largest hurricanes ever already.
Category Five, be careful.
God bless everyone.
And of course in Alabama, nobody from actual
weather services had said, you're fine.
Uh, I'm sorry.
Nobody had said you are not fine.
Nobody has said you need to be worried.
So Alabama immediately in a panic officials,
uh, right away having to say, Whoa, hold on
a second.
The president is wrong.
You, everything's Okay in Alabama, Alabama,
you don't have to evacuate.
You're going to be okay.
And it's stunning that in the Trump presidency,
scientists have been refuting Trump on climate
for the entirety of his presidency.
And even when he was just candidate Trump,
and now even on weather, which by the way,
I know a lot of people on the right are probably
saying, David, what are you talking about?
Climate and weather are the same thing.
No, they're not.
And in fact, that's where a lot of confusion
about climate change comes from.
But now weather services having to refute
Donald Trump on the subject of weather as
well.
Does Donald Trump have any recollection of
the things that have happened during his presidency?
Truly.
I mean, we talked earlier about cognitive
decline, memory issues, etc.
Does he not care to remember or can he not
remember?
Is something actually wrong with the guy's
memory?
So once again, serious questions increasingly
being asked about, would you call this a narcissism
issue?
Is this a memory issue?
Is it a cognitive state issue?
And we had, I mean, it's terrible.
Really.
We had yet another one of these major red
flag cognitive events with Donald Trump over
the weekend, which I talked about at the top
of the show and other slurring and huffing
and puffing visibly confused moment from Donald
Trump.
These are adding up.
There's multiple of these per weekend, and
if you, you know, in a sense the most benign
explanation is Trump is merely such a narcissist,
focused only on himself that he just doesn't
care to remember all of the other terrible
storms that have happened during his presidency.
In a sense, it's the most benign, but it also
is the one indicative of the worst person
possible.
Cognitive decline doesn't mean you're a bad
person.
Memory issues don't mean you're a bad person.
Simply not caring about other people is something
where we could say, wow, he really just doesn't
seem like a good guy, which of course would
not come as a shock to anybody who's been
following this guy for the last 10 or 20 years
or however long he's been around.
A notable in New York City real estate.